so i'm going to respond to something
that perhaps on its own is not worth a
response but it represents a larger
trend and it's it's that larger trend
that concerns me so
one thing i've noticed over the past uh
several years but especially the past
several months is that there's a certain
segment of the right
that somehow can't handle winning or
maybe they don't want to win or perhaps
they're envious that they're not the
ones personally achieving these
victories like they don't want to win if
they won't get special credit for it
whatever it is um whatever we here at
the daily wire have success with
something there are those on the right
who seem utterly determined to find
fault with it
often these are critics who never do
anything of note themselves never land
any significant blows in the culture war
never move the needle at all never put
anything on the line instead they
relegate themselves to the sidelines
while pointing out every perceived flaw
in those who are actually down in the
arena fighting the battles
as teddy roosevelt observed in his man
in the arena speech there are many who
confined themselves to criticism of the
way others do what they themselves dare
not even attempt
now
today i want to focus on just one
example of this kind of thing a
conservative ostensibly on my side who
seems absolutely desperate to criticize
what most on our side would consider to
be a big win
so the website lifesitenews which is a
pro-life news organization that i have
vocally supported amplified many times
over the years i appreciate their
journalism they just published an
article written by um a guy named nick
bell with this headline
matt walsh's debate with transgender
activists on dr phil show left a lot to
be desired
now this is far from the first time i've
encountered criticism from the right for
my dr phil appearance uh you know i flew
out to los angeles to appear on
mainstream television in front of a
hostile audience on a panel where i was
out number three to one there was a risk
because i knew that if i choked or
floundered it would be an embarrassment
that potentially my career may never
fully recover from but fortunately the
embarrassment was all on the other side
of the debate a debate that's been
viewed many millions of times it
represents i think
one of the first times that some of
these basic arguments against trans
ideology have been presented to a
mainstream audience um so that's all
it's all good you know you'd think but
that's not enough for the nick bells of
the world my appearance left a lot to be
desired he says he sits back reflecting
two months after the fact that has
decided that my efforts were simply not
good enough yes you took on three gender
ideologues on national television and
humiliated them he mutters from the
bleachers but could you have done more
and could you have done it better
now i'm not look i'm not taking issue
with the general concept of criticism
i'm not saying that other people on the
right should refrain from criticizing me
or the daily wire anybody else for the
sake of being a team player or whatever
criticism from an ally
can be good and valuable we need to be
able to do that
but when that criticism is petty and
irrelevant and weird and desperate
as it so often is
you begin to suspect that there's some
other motivation lying under the surface
and i do have that suspicion about this
article
as the author bell seems to spend most
of the essay grasping around in the dark
for something to criticize he begins
with this odd paragraph he says quote
the two non-binary guests seem to be
likable enough one is a woman who
believes she's a man and has long hair
and a beard the other is a man who has
successfully blended the characteristics
of both genders to create an appealing
hybrid they come across as well-meaning
people who have suffered due to people
misunderstanding their struggles in that
context simply using their preferred
pronoun seems a small ask
now for the record not to split beard
hairs here but the one with the beard is
a man the other is a woman
i wouldn't call either hybrid
appealing personally
and i definitely don't think my
opponents on stage were well-meaning or
kind or likable or anything like that
and it is indeed a big ask that i should
deny reality for their sake
now he goes on in circuitous fashion
circling around whatever point he seems
to want to make he seems to think that i
was caught up too much in semantics by
focusing on the definition of a woman
rather than the more important issues he
then makes this really bizarre claim he
says that conservatives must quote make
the case that transgenderism inflicts
unacceptable damage not only of those
who dissent from it but also on the
transgenders themselves as well as
children caught up in a social contagion
much of walsh's appearance on dr phil
exemplified the predicament of
conservatives when they forfeit this
crucial piece of their argument well
what
how did i forfeit the claim that
transgenderism hurts kids
i specifically make that point during
the episode i make that point all the
time you'd be hard-pressed to find
anyone in media anywhere who makes that
point more often than i do you know
surveillance is only increasing and the
thing about surveillance is man it's
tough you got to hate that surveillance
i could riff on surveillance all day but
instead i'll just tell you this
you can help protect your data from
being tracked and i urge you to do that
by getting expressvpn doesn't matter
where you live every time you search for
something online watch a video or click
link it all gets tracked by three letter
agencies by big tech or both anytime
they want they can just match your
activity to your true identity using
your device's unique ip address but when
i turn on expressvpn they can't see my
ip address at all my identity is
anonymized by a secure vpn server plus
expressvpn encrypts 100 of my internet
data for protection from any
eavesdroppers or cybercriminals so it
gives you all the protection you need
and the best part is expressvpn makes it
so easy i even have my mom using it who
famously my mom still uses a uh a vcr
and she can use expressvpn too the app
literally has one button you open it up
on your phone or computer hit that big
on button to connect and that's it
you're protected so stop handing over
your data to the government and big tech
companies keep your data to yourself
defend your rights with the same vpn
that i use visit expressvpn.com
matt walsh show to get three extra
months free or click the link in the
description below
um things get stranger from here bell
writes quote walsh went on to bring up
the destruction of women's sports the
dangers of allowing men into women's
bathrooms as other reasons to oppose the
transgender agenda he mentioned the rape
in loudoun county virginia of a girl by
a boy dressed in a skirt this past year
that occurred in women's bathroom
but the left-wing professor easily fends
walsh off by saying that she does not
support open bathrooms where anyone can
go in showing how easily the left can
neutralize the dangerous bathroom
argument by simply taking a compromise
position in this case separate bathrooms
for the transgendered that allows them
to avoid truly justifying the
transgender position
the thing is that's not the position
that the professor took in the episode
she absolutely did not endorse separate
bathrooms for transgender people
no leftist endorses that position
that that doesn't exist on the left it
can't
they want men in the women's room
nothing less than that
they're not going to take like a third
bathroom for trans people
no i i don't want that compromise either
because i don't see why we should make
any special accommodations for people
who are you know confused about their
gender just use the bathroom in
accordance with your biological sex but
but but the left they don't want that
compromise either because to do that
admits
that these are that you know the trans
the quote-unquote trans woman is not
really a woman and they can't admit that
so that's why it's a very good thing for
us to
you know talk about this on a national
on on a national stage specifically the
bathroom issue
we want to corner them into trying to
defend it
because it's a it's a perverse and
insane case they're making
the more they talk about it the better
it is for us so yeah if you if you are
on a stage in front of a lot of people
talking about this issue
you shouldn't be talking about bathrooms
the entire time
but that should definitely be a feature
of your argument
so because you want to force them to
confront that force them in front of all
these people to say
that they want
men in the women's room and the women
who are uncomfortable with it it's
that's too bad for them
so what exact point does the author have
to make that's so important he felt the
need to say it two months later well
as best as i can tell his primary
contention is this which he states early
in his piece
isn't it a bit hair splitting to insist
on perfect logical rigor if the
alternative would lead to transgender
people feeling dramatically less mental
anguish
would that alternative lead to less
suicide would it allow the transgenders
to lead happier lives
later concluding his thoughts he follows
up on the same theme he says instead the
right should focus on the fact that the
very thing these confused people are
seeking their happiness will be harder
and harder to find the further they go
down this road walsh gets closest to
this sort of argument when he briefly
takes exception to the transgender
agenda being foisted on kids but failed
to develop the argument as a result much
of its force was squandered this dynamic
is a microcosm for the state of the
debate writ large the right would be
better served by shifting the argument
from an exclusive focus on girls sports
and dangerous bathrooms to the
well-being of the gender confused and
the increased likelihood for confusion
among children the argument for truth
and honesty and sex and gender is
dramatically more powerful when the true
stakes of the issue the happiness and
wholeness of real vulnerable people are
at the forefront
now you wonder if fell actually watched
the doctor phil appearance or if maybe
he spent the last two months trying to
find a reason to disprove of the
performance and couldn't find one
but he owed the editors an article so he
decided to pull this one out of his
drafts and submit it anyway
whatever twisted path led to this thing
being published the fact is that i do
not focus the debate exclusively on
sports and bathrooms i just don't do
that so what's the real problem here
a lot left to be desired what's left to
be desired exactly he devoted two
thousand words to the subject and i
still have no idea
he's also wrong this is the most
important thing
lots of other conservatives are wrong
about this also so
it's an important point
the primary focus
of our argument against gender ideology
should not be
the well-being or happiness of the
gender confused it also shouldn't be
protecting children
that shouldn't be the primary focus
that's not our first point
now these are obviously very very
important things and we should emphasize
them and fight for them
obviously
but the primary point in our argument
against gender ideology
is that
gender ideology itself is false and
incoherent
that's the main point
if you make something else your primary
focus you're surrendering the strongest
argument
which is that the left's entire position
is insane garbled nonsensical hollow
it's wrong they're wrong simple as that
they are making claims that are wrong
the fact that the false claims harm
people is secondary because the reason
they harm people is that they are false
you can't argue for gender ideology's
harmfulness until you've established its
wrongness that's what makes it harmful
is that it's wrong
if it were true
that you know a boy you know might be a
girl trapped inside of a boy's body and
that he
well if that's true then then who are we
to say it's harmful for him to go out
and pursue
his his true female identity
it's not true it's a lie
and that's why it's so harmful so you
have to start by establishing that it is
a lie that it's false
that's the point of the what is a woman
question it's not semantics it's crucial
it's the core of our argument it is our
argument
so maybe i'm being hard on the author
maybe he's maybe he's sincerely just
confused about my strategy on dr phil my
overall approach to this issue but it
does seem to fit into a pattern
of people on the right some people
noticing a victory on our side
and then laboring strenuously to
discredit it no matter how trivial or
trifling they have to be in their
efforts we already know what teddy
roosevelt had to say about such people
i'm not as eloquent as him so instead
i'll just say to them
you're canceled well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content